do you want to know the business that I
absolutely would uh would get in with
somebody if we found the right person to
do it is Airbnb party houses
so the whole idea of Airbnb is people
rent out their homes but what does
everybody want they want the like family
coming on vacation that's going to take
good care of it like don't have any
parties it's usually written in the
Airbnb uh you know description like
everyone wants the uh really boring use
of their property
but what is everyone who's renting
trying to do right I know a ton of
people who are like damn we're gonna
throw uh a party it doesn't just have to
be like you know Kegs and and uh kind of
like a frat style party but it could
just be a wedding reception it could be
some sort of uh baby shower or you know
whatever
but they want to actually have the party
at a nice house and so if you could find
a bunch of them who said yeah sure like
as long as you guys come here and clean
up afterwards and there's insurance and
you know kind of all the downside risk
that's taken care of like actually I
want people to throw parties here I've
got a great backyard for barbecues or
whatever to me that feels like a huge
opportunity that you know goes directly
against what most people on an Airbnb
want to do with their home
yeah that's such a good point actually
um I wonder if that exists yeah we one
of our airbnbs we
um it was an awesome Texas so this is
like on brand but basically
um our Airbnb manager was telling us
that uh he saw like 20 people come into
the Airbnb but they were all bringing
yoga mats but it was like nine o'clock
at night so it was like what are these
people doing in the house because we
have an outdoor camera there
um and it's a it's a nice house and uh
and basically and then they moved all
the furniture around and we have a sound
audible
um you know measure in each of the
airbnbs we have to make sure somebody
doesn't throw a giant party but
essentially what I think they were doing
is they were totally having like a
psychedelic Journey or whatever in our
house they like left us this ridiculous
Crystal at the end of it it was like so
awesome but um sure there were a lot of
Labyrinth hats you know and whatever
feathers but um but the moral of the
story what we found out later from the
guys like yeah we charged like you know
five thousand dollars a person to to
throw these so if I was only charging
1500 bucks a night and I you know had
your model I I'd be saying yeah I want
5K but have a have a party do whatever
you want set up the shaman crystals
don't care
um so I like that idea oh I think people
would pay Bonkers numbers in Miami one
of the big things that actually happened
uh is I know a couple of folks who they
would come for you know whether it's
Miami Tech week or uh the Bitcoin
conference or whatever and they're like
man it was really hard to actually find
uh an Airbnb uh because I I'm bringing
my whole team and I was like what do you
mean and what they were explaining to me
was they were bringing you know seven
eight ten people from their company that
lived all around uh kind of the country
or the world and so they wanted to rent
a full house or to see or you know to
kind of have seven eight ten people live
in a house in Miami you gotta get a
pretty nice house well it turns out that
the people who have those really nice
homes on Airbnb they know that people
are looking for these like Corporate
Retreat style uh destinations and so a
house that is you know three four five
million dollars they were renting them
out for anywhere between 50 to 75 000 a
month
because the corporates were paying right
so if you're gonna you know how much
would you pay if you're gonna bring 10
people to a city and not only are they
gonna live there but that's where you're
going to do work or whatever for like a
a two-week off-site
would you pay I don't know 35 000 as a
company like maybe that doesn't sound as
crazy because if you start to do like 10
hotel rooms every night for two weeks
like it gets up there and so I was
fascinated with this idea of basically
luxury homes but they're not renting
them to families or to individuals they
were renting them for this more like
kind of corporate off-site uh for
companies that are distributed in terms
of their employee base I love that I
gotta go fire my property manager
because we're not getting 35 000 for a
weekend everybody's fired
um but uh I love that idea I also think
you know I'm really into I think we're
going to talk about this too today but
this idea of
um how can we get people access to these
sorts of Investments so like you know
this Airbnb for instance we own a few
it's kind of a pain like the reason I
own the property management company too
is if you pay the guy 20 to 25 for them
to manage your your properties and
that's a lot of the cut after the you
know whatever 10 Airbnb takes and so um
I wanted to own both but then it's you
know it's also expensive you got to put
the money down for the place it probably
costs you three to five k to get it set
up you know right for Airbnb with
cameras and everything you need and um
and so I was I've been snipping or
sniffing around a lot and this is more
your lane these days too about how can
we get investment access to these types
of deals at cheaper levels and so I'm
messing around there's this one company
called here.co I'm early on in due
diligence with them but I like the model
and they basically let you fractionalize
Airbnb Investments
um so that you know somebody can get in
with a hundred or a thousand bucks and
they've done it in a way where you don't
have to be accredited and so I like I
love the idea I mean when I see the
returns we have rental properties right
normal ones somebody runs for a year
whatever versus Airbnb I mean the
numbers are astronomically different we
keep both because I think it's important
for a market but Airbnb is so much more
profitable if Done Right hey you did you
like this video great we make five of
them a day and post them here on this
channel make sure you subscribe like the
video and see you next time